et
[Musique]
les shadoks sont anéantis par l'insecte
gégène heureusement il y à la lune en ce
temps là en effet sur la terre il y
avait la lune mais elle était de bien
moins bonne qualité que celle de magna
[Musique]
s'était pas encore un astre ni même une
planète
ce n'était même pas un satellite de
c'était un machin machin qui se
promenait à deux ou trois coups des au
dessus des arbres et des forêts comme un
vulgaire ballon deux fois ce n'est que
beaucoup plus tard qu'elle le parti vert
les espaces extérieurs dans les
conditions que nous verrons par la suite
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'en ce
temps-là par conséquent aller sur la
lune c'était pas plus compliqué que de
monter au grenier à condition d'avoir
des echets la lune et d'emporter son
manger alors qu'angers j'ai ne se
déchaînaient
les shadoks couraient se réfugier sur la
lune avec leurs victuailles leur patrie
cuisine leurs ustensiles et leurs
impulsions
c'est ce qu'on appelait en ce temps là
la course à la lune vous devez vous dire
pouvoir à laisser facilement sur la lune
quand on avait des embêtements sur la
terre ça au moins c'était une lutte
intéressante
vous avez raison bien sûr mais pas
tellement
cela s'appelle la course à la lune
voyez-vous cas où seulement gégène
mongel se traînait mais même ceux qui
traitaient pas et bien il n'était pas de
son fait obligatoirement parce que quand
la lune était pleine
en quelque sorte et bien elles étaient
trop lourdes est tombée les shadoks au
trot il fallait les jeter et cela
revenait pour m
j'ai vainement par ceux qui restaient à
ton modèle dépassé le temps comme il
pouvait et quand gégène s'était calmé
les châteaux prudemment rentrer dans
leurs foyers
et puis
ça recommençait et comme sassou dont
plusieurs fois par jour aller sur la
lune en dire de la lune aller sur la
lune descendre la lune monter descendre
c'était exténuant les shadoks allait-il
pouvoir tenir sur la terre à ce régime
là
[Musique]